on your feet inmate I had a camera
installed right by yourself I learned
who you truly are
you up / episode 413 true colors
warden wolf sent him to the metahuman
wing because he found out that he was
the flash and now he's going to sell him
I ain't gonna be nobody's weapon we
gotta get out of here agreed but how he
sort of starts this Prison Break there's
a sort of macgyver-like scene where
berry breaks on a prisoner to super cool
wolf is trafficking metahumans everybody
could get enough stuff it's kind of a
perfect partnership I mean aiming at
deals in medicine wolf has a prison full
of them
Ralph discovers that because he's
elongated man he can shape-shift guys I
think I just figured out how to stop
warden wolf he could easily shape-shift
into wolf and meet Amunet before
midnight and call off the whole deal
before it ever even happens so the team
is mounting their own rescue mission but
it involves Ralph Tarina and the warden
wolf and impersonating him Marquis
something cold and frosty if you please
turns out that shape-shifting is not as
easy as you would think
doesn't you bro how do we stop this
hey guys got your alert sorry I'm late
it's okay Ralph no it's not okay we're
into this whole business partner of mine
this guy he gets a big fat creep he's
only sticking his nose in my business
oh my and he's so shady he's got these
beady eyes and this crooked smile he's
just a real two-face arrived from head
to toe what he's a two-faced that is
my voice do that that's him right there
that's what you see right there that's
me why is that me you somehow willed
your body to shape-shift into Earl's
appearance it seems like your cells can
do a lot more than just a long game
control-z guys I think I just figured
out how to stop warden Wolfe if Ralph
could shape-shift into Braveheart here
then he could easily shape-shift into
Wolfe and meet Amunet before midnight
and call off the whole deal before it
ever even happened right hey everybody
we got some new flash to break down
before tonight's episode something cold
and frosty and there is a new round of
that blast ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter just be a subscriber and
share the video using those tools in the
watch page but there is so much stuff
that they're introducing into the
mythology right now with all the new
metas The Thinker plot the new character
from the future that knows all about the
Speed Force symbols that's probably
related to Barry and iris and on top of
that elongated man's new powers that
obviously they're using for that funny
moment but that's actually a really
powerful ability do you not watch that
and get flashbacks to the end of season
3 with HR apologies
[Music]
HR c
anytime there's a character they can
make himself or herself look like
another character they always wind up
using that for some big twist and
obviously this is more for comedy so
it's more in the vein of thor ragnarok
where loki was pretending to be odin
that was actually probably one of the
best parts of the movie ocean my son
Thor has returned reaching is my boy
ahead you'll be executed for this I'll
see you in the other side oh you
have an actor pretending to be another
character pretending to be another
character so it's like a three levels
deep joke going on but just remember
this is the way that they foreshadow
them using these abilities when the big
villain fights come on later in the
season likes to steal getting powers
obviously that's going to come back
around in an even bigger twist later
this season so elongated man making
himself look like someone else is
probably going to be one of the bigger
twists later on so just keep that in the
back of your mind as you pour one out
for HR may he rest in peace but the
other part of this too is just the idea
that all the metas that the thinker is
rounding up using Amunet black very
clearly the thinker is behind all of
this they don't mention that like the
producer talks about oh they have this
awesome scenario where the warden is
selling metahumans to Amunet black
that's collecting them but what they
don't say is is that the thinker is
getting Amunet to collect them for him
or maybe simply she doesn't know that
she's being played but this is all part
of the thinker's grand plan he wants to
collect those twelve metahumans
but they just want to show you that even
though they got powers they're not evil
people the thinker is taking advantage
of them the way he's trying to take
advantage of berry because it seems like
the jinx character like in these photos
you see her talking to Barry she
actually seems like a pretty good person
that just down on her luck and
circumstances caused her to accidentally
do some really awful things but at heart
she's a good person I think that's been
the big takeaway with the bus met as
this season because Ralph didney was a
douchebag Barry was ready to throw him
back in prison but Caitlin was kind of
like the voice of reason where she's
like people can change I was evil as
killer frost but I'm not a bad person so
Caitlin an elongated man or the example
that these other bus metas can also
do good things too so it wouldn't be
surprised if we wind up at the end of
the season with the thinker and his wife
at odds with each other maybe they turn
on each other one of them goes full big
bad and the other one tries to help team
flash along with some of the bust metas
but again people like Kilgore seemed
genuinely evil so don't be surprised if
like one or two of them try to help bury
but the other two are genuinely awful
people the other thing you may have
noticed in this promo is that they've
updated their shot of STAR Labs that
exterior shot when they go to it they
show the city there's these cars driving
by on the highway this is different from
what they did back in the first couple
of seasons so I think that's just
because their cg has gotten more
sophisticated like you know you go a
couple seasons on the show each year the
CG gets a little bit better and a little
cheaper to do the really big effects I
know everybody's still wondering about
the dawn Allen character we're calling
her that she could always be somebody
else but just most of the evidence is
pointing towards her being Barry and
irises child because she's wearing the
metahumans suppression choker that
Caitlin was wearing a lot of people have
suggested that she might be Joe and
Cecile's baby because they said that
they were having a girl but they
confirmed that she would not be a
metahuman they're like there's nothing
abnormal about the baby nothing special
so I don't think that she would be
wearing Caitlin's metahuman choker if
that was the case so it sounds like
something else is going on don't be
surprised if they try to present you
with some misleading evidence like they
want you to think one thing when really
something else is going on like oh you
thought that she might be Jones the
seals baby because they're having a baby
girl so maybe this person is from the
future but isn't it so weird that she
sounds a lot like Barry and they used
the same music cues when Barry is doing
his science related things on screen
like you hear those strings in the
background then when she's on screen
talking about really technical things
like when Barry does they play the exact
same music it's just like they're trying
to tie her to Barry Allen so just
generally expecting a big left turn
later on when we find out who she really
is but I think it's gonna be a couple
more episodes and don't forget the flash
is going on break for a couple weeks
after tonight's episode so I'll just
remind people about the schedule when I
post my Easter Egg video later tonight
but if you have any big questions that
you want me to add to my video later
tonight just leave them in the comments
below and I'll need the giveaway winner
when I post that video but click here
for my non-spoilery black
Panther review and click here to rewatch
that Avengers infinity war trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight